por qué
[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france
24 yo soy maría clara calle y comienza
la cumbre climática con 26 en glasgow su
importancia es que los líderes del mundo
presentarán sus planes para reducir las
emisiones de carbono y este es un
momento decisivo desde el 2018 el grupo
internacional que evalúa el cambio
climático el ipcc advirtió que para el
año 2030 el mundo tiene que reducir un
45% las emisiones en comparación con
2010 si quiere aumentar la temperatura a
menos de 15 grados celsius un límite que
nos permite vivir y es la hora de actuar
pero todavía estamos lejos la onu reveló
esta semana que a pesar de los
confinamientos durante la pandemia en
2020 se alcanzó un nuevo récord de gases
de efecto invernadero por encima de la
media de la década y aunque la agencia
internacional de energía dijo que no
debe haber nuevos campos petroleros y de
gas para alcanzar la neutralidad de
carbono en 2050 varios países siguen
explorando uno de ellos es reino unido-
el anfitrión de la cob 26 las
autoridades británicas podrían otorgar
una licencia en él de escocia nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis ha pulido
fue hasta el norte y desde allí nos
explicó la polémica
pese a ser la sede de la cob 26 y de
prometer la protección del medio
ambiente el reino unido intenta
desarrollar el campo petrolero campo en
aguas escocesas su objetivo cubrir los
requerimientos energéticos de la nación
campo aún sin infraestructura tiene
reservas de 800 millones de barriles si
car point energy la firma operadora del
campo afirma que la extracción se hará
de manera responsable con el medio
ambiente pero los ambientalistas dice
que el impacto para el medio ambiente
será irreparable te sacan ha liderado la
campaña para que campo no reciba la
licencia
en cambio es un gran campo petrolero
actualmente tiene como objetivo extraer
unos 200 millones de barriles de
petróleo en la primera fase de
producción daría lugar a emisiones de
carbono equivalentes a 18 centrales
eléctricas de carbón en funcionamiento
durante un año lo que es muy
significativo
el partido verde que hace parte del
gobierno escocés acusó al primer
ministro británico de tener un doble
discurso frente a campo
completamente hipócrita quiero decir dar
la vuelta al mundo diciéndole a otros
países que dejen de explotar más
combustibles fósiles cuando lo estamos
haciendo aquí en el reino unido es
totalmente hipócrita y de hecho creo que
pone en peligro las conversaciones de
las 426 porque nadie va a respetar a un
líder que dice una cosa y hace otra
pero las críticas ambientales contrastan
con las necesidades del país
y el reino unido en ese es clara
petróleo y gas durante los próximos 30 a
40 años porque recuerde que el petróleo
y el gas no son solo para usar en
nuestros automóviles o para calentar
nuestros hogares sino también para
muchas otras industrias petroquímicas
por lo que siempre necesitaremos un
montón de hidrocarburos jairo carbón a
pocos días de la apertura de la cob 26
aberdeen ya empezó su transición de
combustibles fósiles a renovables pero
la aprobación de la licencia de campo
parece ser inminente porque el reino
unido sigue consumiendo más
hidrocarburos de los que produce
ante encrucijadas como la del reino
unido muchos creen que la solución está
en las ciudades desde la primera cumbre
climática de
1995 los gobiernos locales y municipales
han participado pero no tienen poder de
negociación
ahora para glasgow desde américa viajan
representantes de la coalición de
ciudades capitales frente al cambio
climático
cs 35 la primera red impulsada desde
américa latina' previamente hablamos con
verónica arias la directora ejecutiva
del organismo ella nos explicó que
pueden hacer las ciudades para alcanzar
la neutralidad de carbono y cerrar la
brecha que dejan las metas nacionales
las ciudades tienen un potencial enorme
para cerrar las
los compromisos nacionales un potencial
enorme de reducción de carbono porque
las áreas como el sector de transporte
de residuos sólidos inclusive la
deforestación que ocurre en la mayoría
de ciudades acordémonos que las ciudades
al 2050 van a tener el 70 por ciento de
la población entonces desde ahí la
primera fuente donde se puede reducir
precisamente las acciones de emisiones
de contaminación la segunda es que en la
mayoría de ciudades también tienen una
riqueza de biodiversidad y que pueden
adaptarse usando soluciones basadas en
la naturaleza entonces si estamos
hablando de que viene una era de carbón
o una era de precio hasta el carbono hay
una gran oportunidad para las ciudades
para comenzar a integrar los mercados de
carbono y por otro lado se viene una
oportunidad enorme para las ciudades en
cuanto a una nueva legislación climática
local para lograr incentivos justamente
para
reestructurar mercados de carbono pero
también a proteger áreas de conservación
alrededor de las ciudades como medidas
de adaptación y de resiliencia a todos
los efectos del cambio climático esas
son las áreas con gran potencial para
las ciudades desde esta coalición de
ciudades americanos han promovido una
negociación subnacional paralela con
temas como la descarbonización del
transporte o las legislaciones locales
para contribuir a reducir las emisiones
le preguntamos a verónica arias qué
temas concretos proponen los gobiernos
locales y municipales del continente en
la cob 26 primero que se les tome en
cuenta como un aliado estratégico para
cumplir justamente las metas del acuerdo
de parís que sin ellas no va a ser
posible luego el financiamiento
subnacional definitivamente no tiene que
pasar necesariamente por los gobiernos
por el visto bueno de los gobiernos sino
que haya recursos directos para las
ciudades hemos visto en el commit como
las ciudades han enfrentado de manera
plausible muchas de ellas como han
sabido enfrentar esta realidad son las
primeras que están en la línea y también
las que pueden responder de igual forma
va a pasar con el tema de cambio
climático son las primeras que puedan
ejercer acciones directas con la
ciudadanía y así nos despedimos esperen
nuestro especial sobre la cob 26 el
próximo 2 de noviembre hasta entonces
[Música]